well come fall 2021 there will be
another option for parents looking
outside of ccsd
yeah a new charter school is open for
enrollment in north las vegas
construction underway near kerry and
civic center just ahead of a fall
opening madison kimbrough spoke to the
principal of pacifica career in
collegiate academy
as well as a parent who already has two
children enrolled
madison yes this is a public charter
school and it is the talk of the town
here in north las vegas
it's a tuition-free k through seventh
grade with the hope of expanding
to k through 12th grade down the line
i'm excited because there's a lot of
things to explore
and things to learn about emiliano and
his sister are
already enrolled in what principal dr
eve breyer calls
the north star of north las vegas
welcome to civica career and collegiate
academy an individualized instruction
academy where the focus is on hands-on
learning through their stem and
career-oriented curriculum
we are looking at our school opening and
we're ready for august and our campus is
looking to be ready on the timeline of
about
july the school is going to be a k-12
school so we're opening next year as a
k-7 and then every year after that we'll
be adding a grade level until we're
at 12th grade we're looking to serve
almost 7 1700 students
when we're at capacity parents like
laura dorateo can't wait for her kids to
start school at civica
as it's right by her house the class
sizes will be smaller
and she doesn't have to pay out of
pocket for her kids to have a good
education i think it's good opportunity
for my kids to start since the beginning
from you know
k first second and stay in the same
school through high school
at first when i would hear charter
school i would say like oh you know like
i can't afford that like private school
for charter schools when i found out it
was free tuition
i think that was like the push that
really make me because i said i mean i
don't have to pay
you know it's just by lottery open
enrollment runs through the end of the
month and a lottery runs on march 1st as
spaces are limited
now as for the lottery on march first
that is specifically for parents that
didn't make the enrollment cut so any
extra spaces
will go through the lottery for those
that applied and also the academy plans
on
staffing the entire school by this
summer so if you are interested in
employment we'll have all those details
up on
our website reporting live in north las
vegas madison kimbrough
8 news now